hi good afternoon everyone
um welcome uh my name is priyana tarajan
I'm the current director of the Frankie
program in science and the humanities at
U our Flagship interdisciplinary program
I am delighted to invite you all back to
today's uh discussion session following
a fantastic colloquium yesterday given
by uh Professor Brian Cantwell Smith uh
the title of his colloquium was
inference in a non-conceptual world and
as part of the nature of inference
series it has been our practice to
follow up the colloquium by a
distinguished speaker with a discussion
and um with a conversant um a
distinguished researcher who might have
a slightly different perspective from
the colloquium speaker the previous day
and it is my absolute honor today to
invite uh Professor Joseph Rouse from
Wesleyan University to be the conversant
and Lead discussion today
um Professor Rouse's primary research
interests are in the philosophy of
science and the history of 20th century
philosophy interdisciplinary science
studies and the social theory of
practices within these areas his primary
Foci include the philosophy of
scientific practice naturalism and
anti-naturalism in 20th century
philosophy the metaphysics of
normativity the connections between the
analytic and Continental philosophy the
relation of philosophy of science to
philosophy of mind and language and to
metaphysics cultural studies of Science
and feminist science studies he has
um many uh has authored many books and
he has a current manuscript under review
social practices as biological Niche
construction and in which he shows how
and why to integrate our biological
conception of human beings as animals
and our social cultural and
psychological conceptions of human
beings as persons and I cultured agents
so um it is a real
um it's going to be a real treat today
to witness
um this discussion uh interaction and
conversation and as per custom I'd like
to invite you all to post your questions
in the Q a feature of the webinar and
before I turn over the floor to uh
Professor browse I would just like to
once again thank uh the support from
um uh Mr and Mrs Richard and Barbara
Frankie as well as the Templeton
Foundation that have made possible this
uh inference series
and I also want to remind you that we
are recording uh this and therefore all
participants are required to mute their
audio and videos
so
um welcome once again everyone and
Professor Rouse
um the floor is yours thank you so much
to both of you and Brian for you to come
back again uh to participate in this
discussion okay well let me Begin by
sharing my screen and then by by first
thanking Thai camp and Priya natarajan
for the invitation the Frankie center
for the sponsorship and especially Brian
kentwell Smith for his very rich and
provocative talk
has taken on the front domain of the
relation between thought and or language
and perception and action and with it
the demarcation of conceptual content
from whatever is non-conceptual
as he notes in the case of Evans and
McDowell disagreements in this domain
often turn on differing intuitions about
or conceptions of what is conceptual or
non-conceptual with proponents then
talking through one another
and one constant difficulty is to secure
non-question-begging characterizations
of what we're talking about
Brian and I also differ in some respects
in the end about what is or is not
conceptual but I'm confident we can
avoid such unproductive failures
so
I'm going to quickly overview the teams
of the talk first first I'm going to
talk about four Central aspects of
Ryan's talk with which I'm largely in
agreement
first what he calls an ontological
rather than an epistemic understanding
of the conceptual and non-conceptual
content distinction
second his emphasis on the fine-grained
richness and continuity of the world
within which conceptual understanding is
situated and to which it is accountable
third we agree on many of the of the key
features of conceptual understanding and
I'll talk more about that shortly
and finally concerning the constitutive
normativity of the conceptual domain
which he in the end understands in terms
of the inseparability of matter and
mattering so I'm going to go through
those four themes first but then I'm
going to raise four primary questions in
response to Brian's talk first I want to
pick up on the question of whether his
initial characterization of a feature
space is the right way to think about
the phenomena he's talking about
second I'm going to ask a question about
whether the world that we inhabit is in
the end non-conceptual
given the pervasive involvement of
conceptual practices languages imagery
equipment music and so forth in the
world
third I'm going to look a little harder
at Brian's conception of the conceptual
oh and ask whether instead of starting
from the kinds of conceptual structures
that say someone like like Evans is
talking about whether we should talk
start from conceptuality in the wild
much as Brian's work on computation
suggests we stop we start with
conceptual with computation in the wild
and finally I want to ask a little bit
about the place of other agents in the
world we inhabit and they're bearing on
the framing and grounding of conceptual
normativity
itself First theme
in Brian's ontological account of
intentionality and contentfulness as
most accounts of this tend to be what he
calls epistemic that is they begin with
an account of what I would call empty
content how someone takes the world to
be and then only then ask whether and
how that content is fulfilled
and that's why epistemic accounts Target
objects as instantiating properties and
relations and groups in the settings
in the sense accordingly
the ontological understanding of the
conceptual that Brian is and is
interested in starts with involvement in
the world
and then asks how aspects of it
are takings of something as something
I mean the difference is that the
epistemic account presumes that the sum
the something is objects and we take it
as having properties is and and
relations and Brian's account
is taking the world as articulated into
uh
[Music]
property objects and properties and
hence and in doing so uh both objects
and properties are in the second
something on the far side of the s
and that's why Brian thinks that
epistemic accounts are actually
implicitly ontological
that is committed to taking the world as
already articulated into objects and
that's what he's of course putting into
question
the second theme and which I'll be very
brief about because
is that Brian thinks that the concept
that you know that there's a kind of
fine-grained richness to the world that
we encounter and that this is Vindicated
in multiple ways first my ordinary
experience whose content and colors and
the speed at which we drive around the
corner and various other phenomena are
you know are have a kind of fine-grained
richness that outruns our
conceptualizations he also thinks that's
true of scientific understanding from
the physics of fields which are not
discreetly bounded to the practicalities
of cartography which have to give
boundaries to Islands mountains forests
coastlines and so forth or where there's
no exactly determinant boundary to that
but first and foremost I think for Brian
this is Vindicated by the history of the
computational and cognitive Sciences
first by the failings of good
old-fashioned artificial intelligence
second by the um
you know the Practical challenges of
real world computation and especially
now by the comparative success compared
to gofi of machine learning and second
wave I AI
I agree on all three of these scores but
I will say something more shortly about
how we characterize it
the third thing some of the aspects of
conceptual understanding that figure in
Brian's account
first that conceptual understanding
abstracts from the diverse actual or
possible particular realizations of the
same conceptual content
second that conceptual understanding
allows the recombinability of its
Concepts in various predicative
disjunctive or hypothetical judgments
and in the late contemporary modalities
and various other reformulations
a third point which he said less about
that Brian emphasizes in a number of
places is what he calls would call the
causal non-effectiveness of conceptual
representation that my merely my
representing something by itself is
non-consequential and that it is also as
such indeternal indiscernible by others
as he puts it at one point you can't
build an app that will ping every time
someone in the world thinks about me
right it's it doesn't have that kind of
detectability
now it's important to realize that this
is one place where the where Brian's
ontological conception really matters
because
if you take conceptualization to be
about a non-conceptual world than on an
epistemic account that's going to lead
to a kind of global skepticism or a
global disconnection right that you know
we're we would be misrepresenting the
world
for Brian that's not the case because
we're already in touch with the world
and that to be genuinely intentional and
conceptual
that conceptual understanding then has
to be concretized back in action or
application what he calls filling in
such that the conceptual content that's
abstracted from then has to be filled in
in a concrete case to which we apply
what we uh what we do
uh Earth sort of initial theme is the
normativity of intentional directedness
this is something that's pretty widely
familiar and indeed is the source of
familiar concern to naturalize
intentionality or conceptual
understanding by explaining how physical
systems that instantiate the conceptual
can be answerable to conceptual norms
traditional approaches to this question
start with what Brian calls statical
Norms truth reference and the like right
and as the target of either
naturalization or for those so inclined
as the target of non-natural
determination by reason and from that
account of the statical Norms it then
builds dynamical Norms of appropriate
uses and inferences
Brian's experiences in the trenches of
computer science cognitive science and
AI suggests that that strategy is broken
back
the dynamical Norms of practice and use
govern the statical Norms of Truth and
reference
and this he points out has a very major
consequence in that case something else
must determine the dynamical norm
something other than merely preserving
the statical Norms of Truth and
reference
you know much more extensive response to
this in his papers than in the talk is
important but unconventional in terms of
the normativity of ontology
for Brian the doomed sense of matter and
mattering
of material ontology and material
arguments or material considerations is
no coincidence but it's in fact integral
to what it is to be material
he further specifies ontology as the
locus of a kind of natural normativity
this is now quoting from the paper from
which the talk is drawn which
abstractions a creature makes unless
what objects there are for that creature
arises out of the constitutively
norm-governed life that that creature
leads
is objects themselves exist in Worlds
governed by significance interpretation
and importance
this is I think a broadly biological
conception of normativity and it frames
Brian's account of truth that's what is
at issue and at stake in conceptual
activity
conceptual judgments are true and the
inferences we make are good if so taking
them and fulfills the normative concerns
that governs a conceptual systems
projects and practices
now Brian notes and then rejects the
widespread appeal to evolutionary
adaptation to provide the relevant
dynamical norms and he thinks that's the
case because he thinks that doesn't
provide sufficient uh normative
articulation
we need not just norms for maintaining a
way of life and in terms of evolutionary
survival but for sustaining a meaningful
life a morally significant life
and these more more richly
differentiated normative concerns govern
not only ethics politics and Aesthetics
but also ontology
how the world we inhabit an answer to
ought to be conceptualized in living
such lives so those four themes I think
are are things that Brian and I largely
agree about
they are also fairly unconventional even
provocative in the context of most
thinking on these subjects eggs
it's even though uh you know both our
views are grounded and on the one hand
in Brian's work on the cognitive and
computational Sciences
both of our work and interdisciplinary
science studies and my work in the
philosophy of scientific practice
evolutionary biology and social theory
despite that agreement and placement on
one edge of contemporary debates
it's I do have some questions that point
to consequential differences in how we
develop and justify these provocative
theses
I will have to be brief I've written
about them elsewhere at some length and
uh in both published and forthcoming
work
so the first question concerns there are
his initial support of speculative
characterization of the non-conceptual
world as a space of features
there's
underlying this there's a certain
there's a tension in Brian's project
that is
trying to give a conceptual grasp of a
non-conceptual world as non-conceptual
and elsewhere he recognizes that for
example in the artificial intelligence
book by talking by giving a
demonstrative indication of the world as
that which
is registered conceptually but can only
be explicated in further conceptual
explications I have a couple of worries
though about the move the feature space
one is that many of the kinds of things
Brian is suggesting might be features of
a non-conceptual world are actually
interactive aspects of our engagement
with the world
I think of Kathleen akins's classic
paper on thermoreceptors as not getting
the there is an objective feature but
how how temperature matters to us or
colors as neither objective features of
the world nor subjective quality and
perhaps above all of Karen barad's
conception of objects is not in as not
intrinsic to the world but rather as
intra active and hence a causal
conception of things
there's a deeper Point as well and that
is that you know Brian distinguishes
perceptual registration of a
non-conceptual world and conceptually
and then doing conceptual work and then
practically filling in this whereas I
think that perception and action are
always going on together all perception
involves practical activity all action
is also perceptually responsive and our
do our engagement with that and the
world we are in is densely causally
entangled so that's going to be my first
question the relation between puzzle
entanglement or features as a as a way
of
of getting at
the richness of the world that we agree
on
second I want to ask a question whether
the world that we inhabit actually is in
the end non-conceptual
and that's because the fine-grained
richness of the the worlds we live in
that we both agree about is also
cross-cut with abstentions words images
functional spaces equipment and social
roles
these elements have a kind of dual
character
right or that is they are also part of
the rich richly entangled fabric of the
world and they are also conceptually
articulated
we need things like Adam Lowe's
paintings and machine learning
algorithms to abstract from our
pervasive concrete engagement with our
conceptually articulative practices
Dynamic articulation actually
exemplifies uh is this this Duality
right a
we know that that people's the phonemes
people utter are continuous and and
indistinguishable and yet but they also
function discreetly to to Mark out
distinct phonemes and and so part of
what I'm suggesting here is along with
Brian that a conceptually Artic
articulated world is not found but we
nevertheless live in it as already made
by our practices
the third issue
concerns whether whether we should start
instead with conceptuality in in the
wild following on Ed hutchins's
navigation in the wild and Brian's talk
about computation in the wild
and I note that despite prioritizing
dynamical norms
Brian starts his with a characterization
of conceptuality as statical
oh
we only get to inferences as connecting
determinate Concepts more or less
determinate conceptual contents
I want to talk about conceptuality in
the work in the wild that is in our
conceptual practices
and that starts with material inference
as integral to conceptual contents the
content of a of a representation
involves its appropriate inferential
connections and with with others
so that there's
second in that context are actual
conceptual engagement of the world
definitely includes the conceptual role
of things like indexicles demonstratives
anaphora and their iconic and expressive
equivalence
including the ways we negotiate
conceptual disagreements via austension
indirect quotation interpretation and so
forth right uh so I want to
you know I uh in this respect conceptual
understanding is not under our control
the ways we articulate the world
conceptually and assess its normative
significance is continually negotiated
with other agencies
human to be sure but I would also argue
non-human
and and like McDowell for uh oh no uh uh
actually it's going back to the
indexicles point I share with how this
emphasis on indexicles as conceptual but
for very different reasons
finally then I would add that part of
why I think gophi failed is not merely
that it didn't get at the richness of
the world but it also abstracts from the
richness and complexity of our
conceptual life and so the moral I would
draw is the conceptuality has to start
with the Dynamics of of of use and not
with the static structures of conceptual
systems
my final question reconsiders
normativity Evolution and the social
ecological world that we inhabit
I completely agree with Brian in
invoking the normative complexity of
human lives and and hence the inadequacy
of appeals to Simply to evolutionary
adaptation
now he
he understandably doesn't say much about
the normativity involved here in detail
he did more than enough for one talk
uh but I note that he does seem to want
to to begin with the ontology of our
conceptual engagement with the world
before situating in a broader normative
space
and I just think that in the end doesn't
work
[Music]
evolutionary biology in its traditional
focus on adaptation won't do
but evolutionary biology now gives us
much richer resources for understanding
dynamical Norms in terms of organism
environment entanglement ecological
developmental biology and Niche
construction among others and so looking
to the end of Brian's talk
I think we need to ask how and why our
practices engage the world at
spatio-temporal modal distances for
which it's conceptual abstraction from
current situations is useful
I think both the need for long-distance
understanding
and the possibility and normative
authority of our conceptual practices
emerged first through the evolution of a
Cooperative cooperatively interdependent
way of life among early hominins and
that in turn enabled our current
practice differentiated way of life
the practices we each take up here and
now
are closely interdependent with other
practices and ways of life that
nevertheless mostly take place at a
distance
and our need to sustain that Cooperative
interdependence among diverse practices
and practitioners is why conceptual
capacities evolve and persist As Long
Haul trucks and highways for engaging
with the world at a distance and more
abstractly that however has to be a a
story for another occasion
great
thank you so much
um Joe for that uh fantastic and clearly
laying out the points of agreement and
the places where you have questions
um that were raised by uh Brian stalk
yesterday and so Grime now you have a
few moments to engage with him before
um we have
our questions readied up for both of you
okay great well listen thank you Joe um
this is a fabulous in fact clear I think
um especially up to the interlude clear
articulation of what I wanted to say
than I myself said it um I want to make
a note uh a kind of Nod to John Hoagland
the late John Hogan the philosopher um
extraordinary that Joe and I both knew
um when Hoagland and I would talk late
in tonight often
we developed a habit of saying to each
other that's what I was just about to
think
some of what you have done Joe here is I
think um
you you've earned this
moniker I think of of respect and
agreement of you know yes that's what I
was just about to think so so thank you
for that and uh for that clear
articulation
um I want to say a couple of things um
I'm not quite sure in what order um
but but maybe this I think maybe one of
the most important things going on in
your response and my characterization is
that I
do lean a little bit towards Evan's
conception of conceptuality
and my sense is you're of a medallion
and I actually am more of a medallion
myself as well in the sense that I kind
of agree more deeply with McDonald I
think his is taking on the issue of
being engaged with the world
um cuts deep
um
so you I think this is fair to say
especially for example in your third
point of dealing with conceptuality in
the world
um that's right in the wild of course in
the world too but um in the wild
I think the kind of conceptuality that
you're getting at is what would be going
on in the wild might include things that
I wouldn't in my talk at least have
called conceptual now they really that's
not absolutely right
the reason issue as to how we should use
this word because one possible question
I could have got yesterday
um and I was wondering if I get it and
nobody actually asked it is the
following look Brian
your sense of remember I said yesterday
that the conception of the ridge didn't
turn the ridge into a court of
conceptual object it was still the rich
object that it was
um
somebody might have asked me look is
there any conceptual ontology or is that
just a sort of
theoretical fantasy that people have
used as a way of explaining actually the
content of language and so on and so
forth and I actually think it it's it's
a mistake there actually isn't any that
human intentionality
never is fully conceptual in the sense
in Brian's consent sorry sense of
conceptuality
um
certainly I think and I think this
matters to the discussion
I do not think that all of our thought
or our use of language is in fact
conceptual
remember I talked about the poets I
talked about that quote from Henry James
and what it was that his words did to
our understanding of afternoon tea
um
now in a way if you went the McDowell
route and your sort of conceptuality in
the wild route you might think that look
that quote from
James is an indication of
of how powerful and sexual articulation
is such that it's not anything like as
restricted as Evan's conception
um
and
and I would probably answer yes isn't it
amazing how powerful human understanding
is
and I'm not sure I want to say that
that's human conceptual understanding so
so I think
the first glass of whiskey we need to
drink is on how
okay
you and I both agree that what
conceptual means is not God given in
advance it has to do with the practices
we're in PhD and all this kind of stuff
and so on and so forth we can recite the
the cannon
what it would be most useful and most
penetratingly insightful for us to do
with this word conceptual and what it is
that it should refer to I think is not
yet known at least I mean I think that
would be a real issue of substantive
well it might look like a mere issue of
semantical debate if the word semantics
is used in Barnes and Noble
um
I think that's a real issue because
where are the joints or boundaries and
so on and so forth in
um in our understandings
um I said that we live in this middle
region and move back and forth and stuff
and in my sense of what I used to pick
up a couple of can you hand me that cup
and
um
what happens
I mean um
what's his name Rick Rush is very good
on this I think the the the how the
forms of representation that actually
guide your hand take over from anything
that is conceptually available to you
and actually guide your hand so that it
can pick up that cup successfully you
know how much of that you want to
include in your sense of conceptuality
and so on so it's hard to know
um
so so we made it for a little bit on
where we think it's useful to bring down
the word conceptual that's one thing
um I do want to make a comment though on
this applies to Evolution and the Richer
Suite of resources it provides us um but
it's more easily explicable I think with
respect to character rod and her intra
intracausal interactions and so on and
so forth there is a causalism that I
think you know Karen is a is a social
construction person she's not a
reductionist on any normal notion of
reduction except I think she has drunk
the causalist Kool-Aid
that underwrites naturalism and she
thinks you can actually give an account
through causal interactions and actually
get everything that way and I
my sense is that what's happened to us
intellectually in our Evolution if you
like is
that forms of causal interaction
and maybe evolutionary arguments and
cooperation and so on and so forth work
were initially what led us
to develop maybe language and so on and
so forth but that we've outstripped
those resources and my sense of wonder
at that which is causally inaccessible I
mean you know the notion of the light
cone for example with and I can imagine
things outside the light cone even
though no one has ever known I've ever
ever interacted with has interacted with
stuff I thought I'd like going and so on
I mean just by definition that's what
lit cone is but the ninthian of a light
cone is not Madness it's actually very
highly accepted and I think the fact
that
we understand it and that we wonder we
wonder at it we wonder at the universe
and so on and so forth
well the second whiskey is
even with its Newfound resources his
modern evolutionary theory still has it
drunk the causalist Kool-Aid or do we
actually need something more than that
in order to be oriented towards to have
deference to wonder about and so on and
so forth that which is beyond
um Beyond any causal interaction and I
have a
I have a ton of respect
um
for that which is not within our reach I
mean Yates was it Yates and man's reach
should exceed his grasp right I
apologize for the sexism but
but the reach of our understanding of
scripts are causal grasp even no matter
how social and historical and so on so
when you take the social grasp and so on
so forth so so that's that causalism the
causal Kool-Aid that I think permeates
what I think you're saying and how it
differs from what I think so much the
causal Kool-Aid is in fact
correlated with any of our other
agreements or disagreements that's a a
question I think that would take thought
but um but that would be um
that would be um
that would be worth exploring
um
and then the thing about the features
and the fact that I introduced this
stuff um
you know conceptually uncertain sense I
tell stories right about look you know
isn't it like this when in fact you're
paddling down the river and you know
whatever and so on
now you can say look that's a causal
that's a conceptual account because
you've used words that would be a
conceptual account only if the use of
words was intrinsically conceptual which
I think my adversion to poets and so on
and so forth suggests that I don't think
so
so that potential critique I think is
hinges on the first thing I was saying
about the use of the word conceptual and
so on is Earth
but I also think that this phrase that
which
that which I
bit my paddle into
that which I drink down and say this is
a fabulous 24 year old years
mokey scotchers
that which I drink isn't rendered
conceptual by the fact that I have
referred to it
by these words that which I drink even
if I and drink are formulated as words
because I think
and this was in a way my point about the
reference of of
that the reference of of
terms towards things that they
conceptually uh structure
I don't think the reference of words is
restricted to a conception of those
right the actual reference the reference
in the world not the meaning
I don't think
that which I refer to is rendered
conceptual and virtual fact that I have
referred to it using even Concepts let
alone words
and so that I think is
I feel as if there's a kind of
profound deference
to how
you know I I'm almost tempted to to run
into what language might be to language
that people might think of as almost
religious
deference to that which transcends my
understanding
I think permeates what I'm trying to say
and I think it's important I don't want
to give that up lightly I think there is
humility and a deference and a
recognition of that which is beyond that
which lies Beyond which people have
struggled to give voice to in human
history in many Traditions mystical and
not other Horizon zone is over and I
don't think it's empty I don't think the
fact that it's being used words is
is uh
is empty so that fundamental deference
the fundamental non-commitment to
causalism and that Kool-Aid
um
and maybe our difference in the use of
the word conceptual and God knows many
other things so
but thank you for your um wonderful
comments yeah
a couple of things that I think are
really interesting here because the
points on which you're
calling attention to the differences I
think
are have relate are all interrelated
okay so we'll start with the causal
point
think that one of the things we've
learned from thinking in the philosophy
of science about causality is that in is
that because that you know that the the
way you're talking about causality
has the same problem that that you think
traditional way of talking about the
world is that is that
call entanglement is re is as rich and
dense and multi we want to say
multifactorial but of course but it's
prior to the to the distinction
articulation right and that
we variously model and Abstract causes
discrete causes and conceptualize them
from that causal entanglement so it's
first of all emphasizing that that we
are in you know that we are part of and
entangled in that larger conceptual
Unity the unity not in the sense of non
and heterogeneity on the contrary
causal relations are in you know
enormously diverse right but we have to
have to do work to to abstract and
structure them
um no um so just to quickly interrupt I
mean aren't causal relations for example
in physics they're always mediated by
what we call as laws right I mean there
are these relations are informed
by conservation laws or what have you
right
well
I have a whole long account of how to
think about laws and you know and modal
invariance which is absolutely crucial
to Scientific understanding
and its connection to the normativity of
scientific practice is and so this is
you know a long long chapter of
articulating the world so but it
emphasizes that the that
laws are
you know our ways of conceptualizing and
projecting Concepts in ways that are
accountable to the practices and
concerns of the discipline so that would
actually fit law government
conceptualization into something like
Brian like Brian's no but look um this
is an agreement I don't think I want it
I want us home
because I think first of all I think
with Priya I mean I think of
okay so this is notion of Effectiveness
in computer science effective
computation and and what that is is
something I um
I'm actually writing about it at the
moment um and
you know an effective property maybe a
causal property I actually think the
word effective in computer science is a
better word than causal because there's
so much complication with pector causal
but but to go to Priya I mean there is a
kind of look falls off as one over r
squared you know he's local in time and
spaces I mean there is something about
the Aboriginal notion of causation in
physics and stuff that you can't
actually you know
violate and and do and do consequence of
work it is absolutely fundamental
computer science would actually be empty
if that were not a restriction
and the question is can you understand
deference to that which is absent
within an account which actually obeys
you know all the other irregularities of
of which in fact
all under the one over r squared falling
off as um you know following up with one
of our kinds of constraints of
Effectiveness and I think the answer is
no and and you know the the fact that
the Saudi Revolution you know can be
characterized as in fact
this fabulous hypothesis on who knows
Descartes part if you like bacon and
stuff
that in fact the world can be explained
in virtue of its causal
nature and its causal laws and stuff has
to have substance if you generalize the
notion of causation to be everything
that we can that scientists can actually
come up with accounts of regularities
and stuff then causal doesn't mean
anything anymore assigned every
Revolution it's not a particular insight
and and and and the thing is I think
computer science shows us that it's an
extremely important Insight that is in
fact had you know differentiates what's
computable and not and if you if you you
know if you generalize ownership of
Effectiveness I can solve a holding
problem for for 25 cents um or even a
nickel
so
so I want to say that
reference is not causal but hanging on
to a notion of causal such that
reference isn't it is actually
fundamental to doing Justice to science
and so I think you generalize the notion
of causation at
the Peril of understanding
what science is and what constrains it
well to them the other point I was going
to make is that that in fact the kinds
of Notions of Effectiveness and the
limits of Effectiveness that you're
talking about are also very very
important for my view as are the role of
modal invariance in the sciences and the
different kinds of modal invariants in
different fields the ways in which there
are law governed relations in the Life
Sciences for example that hold even
under
logical hypotheses in terms of the laws
right I mean classic example that the
one you know that the Fisher explanation
for or sex ratios at Birth would hold
even if the physics of sex determined
and chemistry affect sex determination
were different so uh so we we can handle
that
I agree with you on the point about
let's say understanding the you know
what's beyond the light cone right we
are able to do that with it indeed we're
able to talk about and understand all
sorts of things at distances and Reserve
that we we have no direct causal contact
with okay I mean we're there's a problem
with that the point I'm making is that
you can only do that because you are
already participating in a broad wide
variety of causal practices is that
enable those those that account to have
that conceptual content but but but Joe
I might agree with you but only in the
following sense and this is something I
said to Dan Dennick once yeah which is
look you keep going back to biology and
you keep going back to the evolutionary
account of our emergence and I said yeah
that's the train we got here on I am not
arguing that that's
the train we got it you're on but I
don't think the train of how we got here
is an actual explanation of where we are
you know so the fact that that's how it
emerged which is of course the kind of
explanation of something that someone
who believed and causes would tend to
think was explanatory because he
recognized something by causal emergence
well no Brian here here's the train here
the trajectory matters right I mean the
trajectory matters how you got here
right it does indeed and see part of the
point here is that I'm in agreement with
you that there's more to the world we
inhabit than we can articulate
conceptually okay
but I'm I'm thinking about that in a
slightly different way than you are
because I do think that the ability to
engage with for example the fine-grained
richness of the world and the multiple
multiplicity of in causal entanglement
can be indicated conceptually now here's
the the example that seems to me
striking it's the more which we can be
we can also indicatively
Point towards or there's more to the
world than we understand more you know
more more in the heavens than Earth than
you thought of in your philosophy
Horatio right yeah yeah
that
but that's not
the fine-grained richness which
admittedly
you know we can't reproduce in words and
we don't want to don't want to try even
The Poets are not reproducing it or
representing it in its detail but
evoking it
the contrast is to those aspects of the
world that are utterly beyond our kin
and I think that's one of the things
that the history of the Sciences brings
out for us that that is what it is to
bring whole domains of the world that we
can now talk about engage with
in part of course by
constructing experimental systems enable
us to get it to show up in particular
ways that previously were completely
ineffable right we talk about the growth
of knowledge of the Sciences but
actually what's been most striking is
the growth of what we can talk about
what we can actually engage with and
make sense of bring into the conceptual
domain and they're I mean it's a it's
sort of the Confluence of ideas and
instruments not just ideas because it's
the instruments that enable
new conversations about ideas and um
generally and the practices in which we
employ those instruments and the
situations in which we're I mean here's
a lovely recent example
well the ways in which its genetic
sequencing has uncovered a massive
proliferation of the microbial world
that couldn't be you know we had no clue
this was there because we had no way to
culture it which is the only way to make
to get access to but that's the more of
the world and you know and it's actually
our conceptual capacities which enable
us even to articulate that right so
we're in agreement to a great deal
and My worry is that
we actually need to recognize
in scientific understanding the
entanglement of the modal and the
normative
that conception that causality is not
one kind of relation but a rich panoply
of
entanglements which we then model
articulate and engage with in part of
course by instruments in creating
phenomena in laboratory that is that
bring things out and also by building
inferential relations
including the poetic inferential
relations which do an important sort of
work so I you know you're worried that
I'm you know making the poets too
conceptual
I think Priya was initially worried that
I'm making the scientific understanding
too poetic yes right and and what I want
to argue is that the making of it is
poetic is actually
but the causal Niche construction
reconstruction of the worlds we can
encounter that and that yeah you know
and that involves not just new words but
new practices new engagements it depends
on the stuff
that we have even new Logics oh well
yeah sure no okay oh and the the final
point you know because you you were you
were raising as a as a worry a possible
worry about your talk someone might say
well the kinds of abstract conceptual
structures that say Evans is talking
about don't really refer to anything
that's not
my view is that they have an important
expressive role
in enabling us to talk about the rich
entangled conceptual relations in the
wild but they are dependent just as you
are arguing that
our ability to talk and conceptualize
and represent at all depends on our
involvement in the world which we
completely agree on right that I think
that our ability to articulate these
formal relations are expressions of and
dependent upon the much richer set of
material inferential relations
including the ways in which we differ
about them so you and I can talk about
what is conceptual even though we have
different agreements about exactly what
the conceptual is
because
in the end we're talking about many of
the same practices about scientific
understanding about causal relations and
the question is oh to our teacher that
but I think I don't disagree with you
about the
vast
expensive role of imagination of you
know instruments and practices in
science and so forth how it's opened up
this all this kind of stuff I mean
the flourishing the expansiveness the
you know the richness the entanglement
and tonosaurus all of the things that
you
say which I think Priya is nodding by
is not the best poker player
um
unfortunately I'm not playing poker and
we are not playing poker right that's
good I would have lost already
um
I agree with all of that
the question is is that Jermaine
like how how
how comprehensive is that
the the Realms that are being expanded
by these
discussions you know this is where
you're a barodian and I think the the
um
you know I think this console Kool-Aid
goes deeper than this issue of
conceptual and unconceptual I I think
you
you really drank this Kool-Aid you you
have a sense that
you can sort of get it before I
have to invite Professor to comment here
as soon as you finish yeah
um
yeah no I wanted to I actually have
notes on it um
on a um you know because her her title
meeting the universe halfway is such a
great title but but causal
interactionism I think just
screams at me with the limits of what it
is that her consent her metaphysical
conception right and I want to say look
you've you want to not be a reductionist
and you've you've successfully
achieved not exemplifying so many of the
properties of reduction existence except
the fundamental one which is to actually
think that you could explain things in
terms of causal practices and causal
irregularities and all this kind of
stuff and I don't think
that
what Yates was talking about her
you know it's funny you say that you
know we understand that there's an or
that um
there's more to the world than than is
grandpa in your philosophy or something
um um
you know I think we agree with that I
actually had a quote in my book about
there's a lesson the world that has
dreamed of in your philosophy which I
stole from um I stole from uh
um what's his name um the guy who world
weighs the world like he um um anyway
my dad was an islamist if I can bring up
a different topic and he actually felt
that the right way to understand the
moezin's call on Friday night
was I know that
I know that there's more to Allah it may
be Allah um to all of them I know there
to be or something you know and the
Allah stuff doesn't really matter I
think in these foundations of recruiting
breakfast it's like I know that there is
more than I know that there is kind of
um and the in the and the the
contradictory nature of that I think is
he's sort of crucial and I guess I feel
like why do you say that it's
contradictory I mean it's just having
awareness of the limits of knowledge
right I mean well let me solve your
conceptual knowledge or your ability no
It's tricky because if you said there's
more than the world than I understand
that would be easy
to say that there's more than I know I
know that there's more than I know there
to be is
you know that's kind of I mean it's a
challenge yeah there's another layer
wrapped up there
um
I guess my sense of what has mattered to
me about people I've known just to be
very personal about this is actually
a sheer deference
to that which is beyond
Rich patterns of causal interaction and
engagement and so on and so forth I just
I find the restriction
to
to um you're absolutely right extremely
rich and extremely being better
understood all the time and so on and so
forth patterns of causal interaction I
think in casual engagement and all this
kind of stuff I mean the stuff that the
Scientific Revolution actually opened
our eyes to I think
it just feels to me like a projection
onto the wall of the cave and
that no matter how
Rich the Shadows are
that
there was something to the scientific
revolutions claim that we can reclaim
the universe in these terms even if
Descartes had no idea about the
resources of evolutionary biology now
and and so on and so for the niche
construction and and God knows what
I think it's still a shadow of that
to which we defer right
as I think it is part of what that to
which we refer of course I agree with
that and it only gets its sense as an
ongoing and open-ended
articulation of that right because I
mean the two things right no we would
agree with that but the question is is
that open-ended
exploration
open
to any understanding we get of it or or
is it is it closed methodologically
because of a commitment to cause a less
explanation and I think if if it's the
former then there's nothing to science I
wouldn't
Witnesses but it's restricted right if
you have a commitment to causal
well if you haven't restricted to causal
then I think you're not going to explain
things that in fact the fundamental
constituent regularities of which are
not causal and I think reference is one
thing the fundamental
the fundamental regularities of which
are not causal that's I think the
importance of that impossible iPhone and
see here's he
I think this is where there's actually
more agreement than you think because
reference is a sense in which you mean
it okay so the way in which you can
utter sentences that refer to things
that we are disposily disconnected with
I have no problem with okay we do that
that's one of
next question how do we do that right
and you know
this is where I think the dynamical
Norms of conceptual articulation and the
ways in which the concepts themselves
get their content
from how we engage with the world how we
engage with one another
but Concepts relate to one another
inferentially which allows you to
express new things maybe you have to
write a novel in order to develop the
concepts to point to you know without
often what novelists are doing right but
they're there by allowing us to refer to
things that we previously couldn't refer
to well I think there's truth to that
but the problem is to argue that they do
that in virtue of
Rich causal engagements and stuff is is
circular because in fact if the
reference of the novel is something that
Rich patterns of causal engagement can't
explain that in fact what it is that
they're referring to can't be explained
that way the thing is
um
my sense I mean this is the McDowell
part of you I think that I think is
actually a little bit incompatible with
the broad part of you
one of the senses I have of Mcdowell is
that part of what it is to be conceptual
for him is that it is in fact part of a
conception of the world right and
McDowell is not anyone who's lost any
sleep over not being compatible with any
scientific results
that's one of the virtues being a
Pittsburgh philosophy
foreign
but the thing is the conception of the
world holding things accountable to
being part of the world right which is
something McDowell feels I think and
something Hoagland actually believed in
deeply
I think that conception of there being a
whole world that which is one that
Beyond which there isn't anything
I don't think that can be explained in
terms of Rich patterns of causal okay so
I think at this point we should probably
invite if Professor barad is interested
in commenting
absolutely and also next year you have
to invite us all to bring the novels
we're going to write
well not me
sorry I didn't mean to interrupted no
not at all um I have invited uh
Professor Bharat to um
yeah hi
um thanks for inviting me
um
for this amazing for this amazing
exchange I'm just gonna be super brief
by saying that I don't know how much Joe
is a barodian but I'm certainly a
rausian and I think that he's
um I think that Joe has done a marvelous
job
um addressing Brian's objections about
this and so I'm just going to leave it
at that thanks
thank you so much Karen it was fun thank
you Karen I had no idea you were here so
otherwise we wouldn't have talked about
me drinking Kool-Aid I bet I would not
have no yeah we'll we'll bring you in on
the whiskey
that would be much more fun I look
forward to that yeah that'd be great the
first round's on me thank you so much
yeah
okay
um I mean I guess I have a I have one
quick question but I think I wait and
I'll turn it over to people
um in the audience today and I think Jun
Lau has a question
um it seems that under Brian's
conception of both conceptual and
non-conceptual forms of normativity
there is no reduction to causation
Evolution or practice does the debate
here may not be about conceptual versus
non-conceptual per se but about the
constitution of normativity by Brian's
conception the non-conceptual world
plays an irreducible role in the
constitution of normativity conceptual
or non-conceptual and that aspect is not
captured by causal evolutionary and
practical accounts is that correct
yeah I I mean I think I think my
understanding too but I could have
missed something but I think um I think
children's communist is actually
interesting the last sentence I think is
it's too easy to answer it in the way in
which it's framed and so I want to sort
of raise the anti and then also um agree
with the raised anti-version
um is it captured by causal evolutionary
and practical accounts I think that's
correct it is not
but I would say something stronger is
that the constitution of normativity in
the human case and I don't know about
other biological animals I think this
might be a place we we actually have
sort of transcended our biological
Heritage
um the constitution of normal activity
conceptuality and non-conceptuality in
the human case is not captured by causal
evolutionary or practical phenomena
so in other words it's not just the
accounts it's what those accounts are
accounts of I think that is not enough
so yes I agree with you and raise you
one
thank you so much June for that great
question
um so um so as we wait for more people
to chime in with their questions so I I
wanted a clarification right so and the
clarification is about the negotiation
of conceptual disagreements
so uh
so is it is it that the arbitration or
negotiation between uh different
conceptual accounts
of reality is not actually challenging
per se at the end of the day because you
share a lexicon and a language
or are there you know incommensurable
but you know neither one and I think
this is an important question I think
because
what I tend to do I think would tend to
do with the conceptual disagreement is I
would say look come over
let's just sit down or maybe we're going
to go walk around the field and you know
and
now why
because having dinner and and walking
around the field and having Libations in
common it's on this Earth is a form of
Engagement that is not entirely within
the conceptual realm and I don't think
that
sharing a vocabulary I mean we do share
a vocabulary in some sense right I know
this word
um conceptual for example and um
you know it's different across the
languages I mean it's interesting that
in in French I believe calcium is the
French translation of two words in
English conscience and consciousness
and I have asked people who are native
French speakers whether they actually
have
French makes only one notion such that
if we English have pulled it apart or
what's going on inside and I've had
different answers some French people who
are trained in analytic philosophy and
stuff think look it's just a word that's
used for both things and no French
person is confused and I've had other
French people say no that's absolutely
right and it's interesting and it
matters to French society and so on so
so the point of sharing words is is
tricky but I don't even think
um
if Joe and I who are pretty damn close
in this Pantheon
if we use a word we may use the same
word but that doesn't mean we mean the
same thing or getting it the same thing
and I remember saying this to John
barways and John Perry once and I said
look I don't think that when
um
you know we use you know the words mean
different things in different contexts
of use and stuff and they said yeah no
we agree with that but by and large
within a sort of American society in the
late 20th century whatever you know they
mean the same thing and I said no that's
not right at all I think in fact even
when I use a word I'm not sure it means
the same thing at the beginning of a
sentence at the end of a sentence and
then he said yeah we know so
um I think
thank you
it's not an absolute disagreement it's
not that we if we use the same word that
therefore we mean the same thing I don't
think it means it's incommensurable I
don't think it means we can't learn from
other people you know when I said to
John Hoagland look that's what I was
that's what I was just about to think
my mind can be stretched and it's
stretched by Joe
and he's adjusting you know it's like
um bending a note on a guitar or
something you know we can bend what the
the the word means for me and so on and
so forth I think that the nature of our
Concepts is much more plastic and fluid
and contextual at all of this kind of
stuff then with all respect the question
or at least connotes with that question
and I would want to add there that that
process of ongoing negotiation of our
Concepts and words with one another and
with what we're talking about and
the sense that oh
this is accountable to the world is
really really crucial to all of this so
when you talk about uh you know what our
words mean and what we're talking about
right a
what I I want to draw a slight
differentiation there right because I
come into our conversation with let's
say a word like conceptual or a world
like causal with richly entangled set of
inferential relations which differ from
yours okay there's some overlap but
there's a lot of differentiation and
you know and we but of course
we're committed to the idea that as I
think characteristic of what it is to be
conceptual that this is that these can
be adjudicated and worked out not that
we will but that they can and this is in
this involves
reworking and engaging that you know
and something like the very Point you're
making that the that objects and and
properties are on the far side of the
something as something right that we're
having to renegotiate
what we think you know objects become
the point of contact and ostensive of
pointing out I'm talking about that and
yes but I mean
differently than I do right that
provides a point which is then you know
exactly what we mean
by what we should mean
buys ahead of us so this in that sense
on my account normativity and
temporality are
normative normativity of and
conceptuality are temporal phenomena
is stability of meaning a casualty then
without I mean is there stability of
meaning or
I think think about being in the North
Atlantic in a small boat um if you're
standing in a small boat in a North
Atlantic storm
stability doesn't come from being rigid
if you stand rigidly you're going to be
tossed into the drink
stability arises from being extremely
capable of dancing
um and so I think
there are stabilities that require
exquisitely find orchestrated movements
in some of them but but the thing I want
to say to Joe here is
think about maximizations of arithmetic
and stuff um
how do you negotiate different logical
systems and so on and so forth right and
figure out whether in fact you know
piano arithmetics consistent or whether
in fact you know
getting rid of you know you know what's
his name Peter Axel who has this Axiom
that in fact allows self membership in
sets but the whole thing's consistent
there are norms on on maximizations
arithmic now all the accentizations are
going to be effective right because in
fact if you don't let you don't require
syntactic activation to be effective the
whole thing drops into into vacuity so
they're negotiate and then there are
theorems about these things
but they're meant to be asking
maximizations of arithmetic kind of
mathematics and stuff and those things
are not themselves effective subject
matter and I I don't think the
the development of maximizations of
mathematics
of course it has an effective causal
history it has to because in fact we're
all physicalists
but
but the fact that it has an effective
causal history doesn't mean that it's
explained by
the
syntactic manipulations right I mean
that's one thing barwise said that was
the fundamental result of 20th century
logic was that you couldn't reduce
semantics to syntax and we're in
agreement here well but then the
question is can semantics be given
an account in
in a
boy Karen I have such respect for you
that now that you're in the audience I'm
very reluctant to speak
um
and you give an account of
and you give an account that explains
the wrestlings in the foundations of
mathematics with tax immunizations of
arithmetic in in the terms of these
complex patterns of entanglement and so
on and so forth and my intuition is
ultimately no you've got to actually
refer to
the mathematical entities that people
are trying to give
you know explain you know through a
glass Darkly I don't know
but Brian
Karen gonna come in on there that was
that you Priya no no it was just me uh
I'm gonna say that we have a couple of
uh questions as well okay
um so there's one that Ty has Tai did
you want to go ahead first yeah
absolutely thank you for this exchange
um in the article Brian that you
submitted for your talk page the third
day so you write about the registration
effect of Lowe's painting right versus
the abstractness the abstraction of
presentation of Magritte in the
treachery of images otherwise known as
so from my limited understanding for
what I gleaned from the article our
civilization was not until fairly
recently it seems producing paintings
like Lowe's is that because we had not
yet evolved enough to extend what you
call that middle distance and if so uh
what kind of painting might we evolve
into the more we learn to extend said
middle distance well from you you have a
historian of Art and historian of modern
contemporary art here so I know so now
I'm I'm on
a Mad Dog and an Englishman right I'm
gonna I'm gonna tread for Only Fools
would go um
think about my name is red
um
you know or in comics book about Islamic
Miniatures and so on and so forth right
in the paintings talk in that
and there's a painting that says look
you know in the sort of conversion to
modernism and stuff
I wasn't meant to represent what a tree
looks like I was meant to represent the
soul of a tree or something like that
and
I'm not sure
I mean think about
um prehistoric you know images
um
of pregnancy goddesses and so on and so
forth I'm not sure that they were
they were not synonymous and people type
representations
so I don't know if it's true that it's
only recently that
we have paintings like
atoms painting of that door I
I
would defer but we've got to invite Adam
um
I'm not sure I'm not sure I guess is
what I'm saying
you know I'm also going to step into
where I where I shouldn't be trading but
I mean you know Adam's paintings have do
have a history they think back to
impressionism and the effort to capture
the look of things right and
part of my point is that the ways in
which we depict things and how we
understand depiction and articulation in
in painting it's also conceptual oh oh I
don't I have no idea whether Gary
Tomlinson is here in the audience at
Yale but uh get you know Gary's work on
music and its relation to language is
also I think A really lovely example
here to actually see
the kinds of expressive capacities of
music and
what it and how it articulates aspects
of the world
I'm not tripping this to Gary by the way
but but oh you know what that is comes
together with
the kinds of practices that allow us to
take things as being about something
else
right that was the dramatic innovation
of practices which are in in which we
are dependent upon one another in ways
that allow us to take
what one another is doing as not
you know
stuff to do now but it's about something
else and that so Joe do you think every
instructions
you know I mean what is
what you know what is Adam's painting
about and of what is yeah now of course
there's those the other forms of
pictorial articulation and depiction are
working in different ways and you have
to actually
get into
how they're working and what they're
doing and how they're you know how
they're seeing things as and that is
both the things and and the the yes
right but do you think
I mean I guess I want to say is is
I mean I think they're two points of
disagreement here which which are
conspiring together and and that's what
that's kind of tricky more than two I
think actually okay
um yeah maybe nine of them are rolled up
but but they're all connected together
it's one agreement that has multiple
elements but I guess what I want to ask
is look Yates and
Henry James and the bhagavad-gita and
stuff they all use words
does that mean that they're all
conceptual
it's for you
it's not that they are words that makes
them conceptual it's in part they're you
know their but they're belonging to
conceptual and discursive practices that
makes them words
right and and
that you know
we speak a language and that gives us
extraordinary expressive resources
you know Way new ways of combining them
and speaking them speaking those words
and engaging them in various settings
that of course go Way Beyond you know
they are
in Rich ways that are not simply
mathematically functional
right yeah I mean that's what I was
trying to talk about yesterday with with
nunberg's um characterization of the
rise of information that yes languages
and I agree with you on that I mean you
know this this is this is not
concatenations of information right it's
not going into temporary but hey that
and I think the whole of conceptual life
cannot be adequately treated that way
well okay so suppose we agree on that
um
then if I ask you what you think about
this
McDowell debate uh Michael Evans debate
about can there be conceptual
non-conceptional content
is it unfair to say the following you
know something that's me does Joe Rouse
believe there can be none because I
forgot and I say to him this person or
whatever
no Joe does not think there can be
non-conceptual content because the very
idea of conceptual content is for him
sufficiently
comprehensive with respect to our
discursive practices that anything we
say is going to be located in this
historical and grounded and
contextualized practice such that that
and and conceptual content for Joe is to
be something meaningfully conveyed in
that practice and so therefore it's by
definition there can be no
non-conceptual content how much
Injustice does that do to you well
I have problems with all of that okay
good enough
with the notion of content
right that is that I think that we can
only
do anything conceptual as part of a life
engaged in the world
interactively in an ongoing way and uh
having these practices which are on the
one hand very very closely
interconnected so we think about
painting practices and the ways in which
they comment on previous painting
practices but also are accountable to
these larger more long-distance
engagements right I mean impressionism
arises in the 19th century for a week to
do with
uh the insufficients the perceived
insufficiency of a mechanistic puzzle in
the narrow traditional sense
and so you know but they make sense in
response to that and so what I want to
see us talking about is the way in which
to push your point against the epistemic
accounts of the conceptual further I
mean I think you owe your your conceding
to to epistemic conceptions of the con
account of
conceptualness that we have to think
about concept use as practices and
reference referring is something people
do and they do it by participating in
practices which enable us to then
makes sense of and understand things
like referring beyond the light cone or
pointing to those aspects of the world
that we don't even have access to right
didn't have access
I agree with you before that I agree
with you about participating in these
practices
I guess a lot of people that I interact
with
have an automatic
causalist account of practices
but practices are things that
involve bumping and shoving
um
you know that are subject to one or
where our squid laws whatever that
preserve energy I mean
all of these kinds of things
um
and I think
so I remember asking did I mention this
did I mentioned this com this question
to Alonso Church in the talk yesterday
um somebody um I don't think he did I
don't think you did yeah anyway okay so
so Alonso Kirkman was still alive of
course I was giving this talk um at
Stanford and I was nervous and sat on my
hands and didn't think I was going to
say anything but my imagination uh often
unseats my pulley tests
and I asked him after the talk
if I refer to the Sun
does it take eight minutes for the sun
to get referred to
no no no no no I know but I just want to
tell you what yeah sure
you don't have to be Alonso Church to
answer them
but
two things first of all Alonso Church
said reference travels at the speed of
logic which I think was a brilliant oh
brilliant
even though I have no idea what the hell
it means but it
but the thing is what I what matters to
me is that there is a property of the
Sun
that it was referred to
it's not just a property of us that we
referred to it it's actually a property
of the sun such that it was referred to
and that property obtains of the Sun
and now the relativity gets tricky does
it obtain of the sun right now I mean
it's not even a coherent I have to defer
to Priya here
well I don't know I think we could get
into a big controversy now I think
avoid this about whether it's really a
property of the sun I mean I think the
eight minutes is not a property of the
Sun well no but it's got to be a
property of the Sun in the sense that if
I think a thought about you
that's about you that's got to be a
property of you
that you were thought about I think if
you lose that you lose
you know we're in the Trump right-wing
Vortex I don't quite think so I think so
but let me I think Peter Morgan has been
very patiently waiting with this
question
and well he has a couple of questions
um so he quotes said by Professor Rouse
in paraphrase there is more in the world
than we can conceptualize
there is that in the world that we have
so far conceptualized how do we fit or
place what we discover and conceptualize
tomorrow into what we have so far
conceptualized are there ideas of
distance and betweenness as systematic
indications of how surprised we are by
new discoveries and conceptualizations
and this also plays to what Professor
Rouse just said an ongoing discussion
places new uh utterances relative to
previous utterances which then can be
adjudicated and worked out
systematically
we have to allow a story to continue
right I mean that's his third question
and and of course you know the notion of
distance here here is not spatial
distance right I mean
microbes that were inconceivable to us
uh except you know
in the sense of well there might be such
things that we can't
at you know an abstract way right yeah
that's right and an abstract and empty
way okay but that notion becomes
concrete and Rich once you are able to
engage with age with that and of course
you can only do that by drawing on and
extending the resources including the
material practices that you already have
I mean this is one of the key features
that now thinking about philosophy of
scientific practice that is Con you know
that the science is exemplify taking
what the you know the relationships they
uncover and now turning those into
resources for
bringing out other things that's part of
how the Sciences expand
the uh you know the realm of the
conceptual and also of course close that
close off aspects things that it once
seemed to make sense to talk about and
now only makes sense to talk about in
quotation marks right you know hey I
mean and I think think about when they
when they referred to flagistan
this gets at the heart of the fact that
um scientific discovery as we refer to
it is inherently provisional I mean that
science itself is really our conceptual
understanding at any given time is
deeply professional and it's also
temporarily extended in directions it's
drawing on a history that gives us
open-ended resources and allows it to be
to point Beyond itself yeah of and in
ways that and and you know you talked
earlier about not being able to Define
Concepts that's that's because the
concepts always
involve more than we're able to
articulate now in detail right uh
typically
we have an opening of a space of
exploration
and the words we use I mean think of the
history of the word Gene
oh yeah the way it went from a merely
hypothetical entity to
you know to physical to chemical to
structural to information theoretic in
quotes to then being these complicated
regulatory
networks right
so epigenetically yeah it's become an
amalgam of everything that it meant
right so sort of so then you have to
think about it and of course
what how the use of that word is going
to get tied into practices and what
follows from it including of course all
the other non-scientific resonances the
way in which its history was connected
to notion and especially the information
notion of you know Notions of an
immaterial soul that is at the heart of
the body that that inferential
connection was so crucial to the history
of 20th century biology
there was a great um thing that John
Hoagland and I used to say that of
course there have always been electrons
but there have only always been
electrons since Rutherford
right oh so let's not much as I um am
fascinated by Bruno LaTour let's not go
down the latorian tunnel here with um
whether a pasture or whether all right
right you know Bruno tried to get at
some of that in one way but that's but
that's not quite what Brian was saying
right
no no yeah yeah but I think it's totally
connected to this temporal externalism
that I'm emphasizing as well I mean
right Bill and John and I actually have
a lot of a lot in common on that and
great we do we do that's why these
disagreements are so
unnerving
well it's
been this was a lovely point that Ian
hacking once made if two people disagree
Point by point on a half a dozen issues
that they also take to be really
centrally important it means they agree
on almost everything else right very
nicely characterizes you and me
so um I think before we close
um there's a request uh from one of our
guests Stephen uh who came up but uh
Professor Rouse be willing to share
uh his slides
um
we can then add that on to
um our video uh or yes should I should I
send that to Ty or do you yeah can you
please go ahead to send it to Thai
enough I will do that thank you thank
you I'd like those two
so I think uh let me see if there is a a
quick question so that I I um
I think okay there's a there's a
question it's not going to be quick but
we'll try to wrap it up uh soon
um so listening to this wonderful
conversation it's June Lao again one
wonders whether Brian and Joe understand
subjectivity scientific practices human
language Etc differently it seems that
for Brian's subjectivity and any sort of
human doings is as non-conceptual as the
world is non-conceptual similar to a
digital circuit even with all the
correct Arrangement it still needs to be
taken to be digital for it to be digital
but for Joe this does not seem necessary
is this a fair understanding
foreign
so it's up to Joe
well
subjectivity is typically not one of my
words
right I think I think it has too many
problematic connotations which don't
belong together many of the things that
people talk about on in those terms are
really important okay
and you know
the kinds of discovery of subjectivity
whether it's in things like
impressionism in painting or in you know
the interior monologues of Joyce and so
forth right uh is itself
a reconception is you know in this sense
we now want to say that before Joyce
there were interior monologues right you
didn't have the same conception of
interiority right for it for it to show
up that way so
oh
the kinds of things people want to talk
about in that in that way are important
but we needed a better vocabulary and a
better set of practices for engaging
with it many of which have this kind of
character of subjectivity as a kind of
self-enclosure right which I think you
know uh the subjective inner and the
causal interactive outer and that just
seems to me really distorting of both
okay so that would be my answer okay
great
um although we could keep going I think
uh in the interest of our audience's
stamina we should uh probably bring this
to a close and I just wanted to say
thank you very much to uh Brian and Joe
for this wonderful exchange
um and for clarifying A lot of things
for us about
um that the commonalities and the
differences in um in your uh conceptual
understanding of the world I'm going to
just like enlarge it too thank you all
this has been a delight yes thank you um
especially Priya um but also um guy and
Thai and and yes Karen and Joe and
everybody yeah and I want to thank the
audience for being here and
participating and engaging with us so
with this we bring the inference
understanding the nature of inference
colloquium series to a close thank you
everyone and have a lovely evening bye